in today's episode we are going to be
talking about the biggest opportunity
for real estate agents in 2024 so Sean
can you tell us why real estate agents
need to be using YouTube in today's
market yeah I think what's interesting
about a 2024 World Is that real estate
in general is in a very precarious place
and so if you're a real estate agent if
you're a loan officer if you're in the
real estate game at all the market is so
slow transactions are down some people
might be doing all right but I know a
lot of agents are struggling and what
you're ultimately looking for is you are
trying to grab whatever piece of the
markets you can of buyers and sellers so
the questions that we should be asking
is H how do we do that one of the
answers is going to be social media and
one of the best Platforms in my opinion
the best platform to be on is YouTube
for a lot of practical reasons that we
can unpack but the big idea is so that
you can survive this kind of real estate
recession that's happening so that you
can thrive so that you can have your
transactions up um so that you can
continue to build your brand and so that
you can also position yourself as an
real estate agent or real estate
professional for coming out of this
Market I mean let's survive through it
let's Thrive if possible but let's also
position ourselves now to make the next
1 three five seven years of your career
incredibly prosperous agents that have
YouTube channels that are thriving just
have an advantage over those that don't
absolutely so the the opportunity is
real the the need is definitely there
for uh real estate agents to be moving
on to YouTube but why is YouTube so
powerful yeah yeah there's a couple
reasons I think one of the biggest ones
is actually just practical search so let
me tell you a story personally um real
estate's may be kind of a hobby for me
we definitely uh we've done some
short-term rental stuff a little bit of
um long-term rental stuff we own a few
properties um I'm friends with a lot of
agent agents I've spoken at a lot of
conferences loan officer conferences so
I'm I'm immersed maybe more in this
category we help business owners overall
but I'm heavy into real estate so I
think about um and then I look at real
estate all the time so the interesting
story is one of the areas that I'm kind
of looking and shopping in for our
personal and for short-term rentals is
Snohomish County and SN homish county is
an hour north or so of Seattle
Washington which will be King County and
one of the things things that I will do
is as an elder Millennial and all
generations but even younger Generations
they're looking for information on the
internet I'll go to YouTube and I look
for Market updates I'm looking for
somebody that can give me specific niche
market updates and so I will look at
Snohomish County real estate and what's
so fascinating is that in a 2024 World
there is still almost nobody making just
basic videos about the sish county
market and now we're talking talk about
I want to say 2 million people in that
market you know I'm sure hundreds
thousands of Agents but it's wild when
people think things are so crowded
there's barely anybody there now one of
the people I do see is actually somebody
I went to high school his named Zach
McDonald and when I was doing this
search to kind of look at what's
happening now what are the numbers what
are the opportunities what what are the
what's the unique information for this
local context I saw him he's kind of
consistent but not even super consistent
in SN homish now I have multiple friends
that content and they're doing other
platforms but I'm like you're not even
doing the basic thing like you could be
doing weekly even mon you know at
minimum monthly Market updates and
what's so cool about real estate is it's
a little bit different than other things
where there's that realtime opportunity
meaning things are always changing rates
up rates down what's happening now how's
inventory now educating buyers um and
sellers about the opportunity of this
season this is what you should do
because things slow down around this
month and so to summarize um I think the
myth people could believe is that
YouTube is crowded but I would argue
that for most smaller towns different
regions different counties it's not as
crowded as you think I could hear the
argument that in Las Vegas where we are
recording this right now um Dallas or
something there's going to be certain
areas that there's may be more
competition but even saying even if
there's already somebody dominating or a
few channels doing it that's practical
search-based um and then I think
expanding on the idea of search is also
just pros and cons of moving to this
particular City or this particular you
know area um six things you should know
before you move and you stack up all
these different factors search base
means you can get discovered when nobody
knows you you can create strategic
videos that people find not just by
searching YouTube but even by searching
Google especially because if I search if
I type in you know s homish real estate
market Market January you know 2024 no
when when nobody else has made content
on it or only two people have you're at
the top of search and when we start
thinking about one transaction one lead
can change your life you know it can it
could help you especially if you have no
transactions happening of course 510 a
month can really change an agent's life
so you don't need hundreds of views or
even thousands of views on the video you
just need the right views so if you
could think about the search what are
people searching for what kind of videos
can you make and that can then attract
people to you um and then I think the
next benefit is the fact that video
accelerates no like in trust so people
if they're just trying to kind of cold
call an agent or they just get online
and they search for somebody it actually
accelerates them deciding if they like
you or not which is very helpful because
they go okay this person answered my
questions they seem knowledgeable they
they've given me raia result results in
advance they've given me knowledge in
advance they've added value to me in
advance it's scaled because you uploaded
a YouTube video you've been busy all
week but that video is working for you
being discovered in search they watch a
few videos then they call you then they
you know shoots you an email shot shoots
you a text and they're like man you know
I discovered you on YouTube um so cool
to uh you know hear some I got to know
you a little bit and I I heard you know
you wo in a little story I heard you got
some kids I got kids too and you're kind
of you're building some Rapport even
before you get on the phone some trust
even before you get on the phone we have
some students who following our
strategies do deals without even meeting
people there's docu sign is happening
All Digital because of YouTube no like
and Trust so there's so many benefits
you know that's why I'm we we even as
long as this podcast can be in as much
value as we can cover it's actually why
we're doing a whole separate class um
because there's massive opportunity to
grow in real estate using YouTube right
now yes we just performed like this huge
Nationwide study all about getting
started on YouTube and one of the stats
that was revealed was I believe it's
like 42% of people said that they were
more likely to work with a service
provider if they had a YouTube channel
that's that's huge it's 42% of all
people almost 50% would choose somebody
who's on YouTube over somebody who's not
and so just that idea like you're saying
of accelerating no like and Trust
personally I am it's like 100% for me
I'm going to use somebody if they have
an online presence because I need to be
this this new era we need to see that we
need to see your presence online in
order to even validate you as a service
provider I think that's the new standard
I agree and our friend Rory Vaden he's
actually one of the people that helped
us perform that study and hooked us up
with the agency that helped us he did a
nationwide study about personal brand
which is so intertwined and similar that
people will pay more if you've got a
personal brand online that they could
trust they'd rather work with you if you
got a personal brand so agents kind of I
think already understand that in the old
school way it's that nice head shot
those photo shots you're on a bus stop
you're on signs you're putting out
flyers you're thinking about all that
stuff that stuff's not even bad I think
that sometimes as people go digital you
should continue to do uh maybe some of
those things if they're effective but
now in the new school where are people
they're on Instagram they're on social
on YouTube and 100% it elevates your
brand and back to the snom story if
we're in a market where I ask my friend
Anton who's not just an agent but he
runs a whole team and he is doing
apartments and flips and all kinds of
stuff he's pretty busy he's got a
partner they're doing all kinds of stuff
I said how many people do you think
agents and loan officers may get wiped
out and not be able to
survive this coming real estate
recession just with transactions going
lower and If the Fed stays higher for
longer interest rates stay higher and it
just the housing market is frozen my
friend Michael Zuber says the housing
market is broken but transactions will
so happen deaths uh marriages um or
divorces people forced to move forced to
move for their career there so there's
always going to be transactions it's
just not as fluffy as it once was or the
volume uh that it once was he said 80% %
he goes I think 80% of agents and loan
officers are going to go out of business
wow in the next 6 to 12 months so my
argument is for sure he's somewhat right
whatever the number is how do you then
create Insurance how do you just protect
yourself well then you got to be in that
20% so if there's 10 agents eight don't
have a YouTube channel and they don't
invest in a personal brand two do other
factors are certainly involved of course
you got to know your stuff and you got
to be putting in the work but like
you're you're just going to lose to the
person who listens to this podcast
starts takes action invests in this kind
of stuff and so you want to Stack the
deck in your favor and be thinking about
how you can prepare how you can pivot
how you can Embrace modern technology um
and where attention is and so I think
it's just a no-brainer especi in good
times as well but especially in hard
times well there's a whole another layer
to this and I'm I'm skipping ahead and
probably where we should be in this
conversation but there's a whole another
layer to this that's also income
stacking right so it's not just about
even being that 20% that survives and
keeps getting transactions but it's also
about creating other Paths of um revenue
for your business when and YouTube
provides that as well yeah and what's
Wild is here's a tactic that's
fascinating is Anton uh created and I do
coaching with him and again he's a
friend up in sish doing lots of
different real estate stuff and because
he has Diversified his business because
sometimes the question comes up do I
only focus local can I also give advice
that might be International not probably
International maybe but uh Nationwide
because if you get awareness views leads
Nationwide you know are you where's your
license what states are you licensed in
well there's different creative ideas
that people do because leads are
valuable in general sometimes there's an
exchange you split a commission if you
introduce somebody to an agent in a
different state so he has a form that he
promotes to people that has like maybe
12 10 or 12 boxes what are you
interested in are you interested in
buying are you interested in selling are
you interested in investing are you
interested in wholesaling are you
interested in uh land do are you
interested in collaboration because when
you start thinking a little bit bigger
and outside of the box if you only have
two magic tricks in your bag of tricks
great but you're going to be more
limited than the person that has 10 20
and
so getting into
YouTube and starting to use it
practically to survive and thrive right
now in real estate great but then think
about how your world can expand your
brand can expand you can expand into all
kinds of income streams one of which
being that YouTube itself will pay you
eventually and real estate is also one
of the highest RPM CPM topics and so to
clarify what that is for listeners
that's just the amount of money YouTube
pays you for 1,000 views and if you
compare it to one of the lowest RPM CPM
niches and topics would be something
like cat videos or like silly dancing
videos from Tik talk just because you
think about who is watching them but
when you're talking about personal
finance Finance real estate the cpms and
the RPMs go way up and so there's so
many Downstream benefit benefits from
punching fear in the face getting
started on YouTube learning a new skill
set and um it's really just the tip of
the iceberg to maybe get a transaction
or two increase you know per month as
you get started but later on there's a
lot of good that can come your way when
you master YouTube absolutely I was just
talking to somebody in our community who
has uh she is in Hawaii so there is an
advantage to that but she's a real
estate agent in Hawaii and she is seeing
so many views coming in just from people
just wanting to look at houses in Hawaii
I am one of those people who loves
watching like House tours and things I'm
not even in the market but I just am
curious and so she has built her YouTube
channel and gained more subscribers and
Views and and again bringing in that
second um income stream just because
people love to watch and so she's gotten
really good at creating those kinds of
videos so again that income stacking
opening up new opportunities and
supplementing her income while also
still bringing in New Leads for her
primary business so the opportunity is
huge and like we said it's necessary for
people to take advantage of it in 2024
so with that said what was your advice
for real estate agents who are just
getting started on YouTube yeah I mean a
couple things I think one um you got to
start before you're ready you might have
a few few things going through your mind
okay I get the benefit but now Sean
Melissa what if people judge me um what
if what if I get criticism what if I
look dumb I don't really know what to
say well number one make sure you're
subscribed and make sure what's I mean
you just were telling me what is the URL
for the class we we got a pretty URL for
it realtube class.com okay so we're
going to be doing a free class so
definitely register for the class
because we'll get into more nitty-gritty
and we'll link that up in the show notes
realu class.com um but there's okay what
if I look down what if I get criticism I
had a phone conversation with a a friend
who's a uh it was an inperson
conversation who actually is a
bivocational pastor uh her and her
husband are leading a church and then
doing real estate and that's their way
of making income and a lot of the
conversation was actually about do I
need a fancy camera I want to project a
certain image I want to look
professional legitimate point there we
often times say you know don't worry
about that but and but my encouragement
was okay the same as you would want to
however you want to dress present
yourself get your hair did you know
whatever all that kind of stuff well for
sure but I was like um and and where her
mindset was at is I know a few people I
could hire that could be videographers
and that could help me and what I would
encourage listeners that may have that
mindset of maybe overthinking it what if
I don't you know what if somebody judges
me because I I don't have the look or
the vibe and I'm like listen no your
smartphone in fact my advice to her was
make videos in your
car here's why your car actually is like
an audio Booth you know when you it's
kind of noisy outside there's lots of
road noise and then you close the door
to your car and it's like boom calm
quiet um that actually is one of the
best environments to make videos Simply
Now secondly it is actually pretty good
lighting because if it's the daytime
you've got light coming in but it's kind
of softened a little bit if you're not
like actually having direct sunlight
hitting you just general daylight you
got good audio and then I was like you
know set your phone on your dash and for
many we probably already have one but
you may have like a dash mount for your
phone so you can look at the map when
you're driving around and then maybe
plug in a wireless microphone or
something like that in fact we usually
don't recommend gear on the podcast but
there's a wireless microphone that's 20
or $30 on Amazon we'll link it up in the
description uh you could either get the
USBC Plugin or the iPhone plugin plug
that into your phone and you can shoot
videos if it's less than 60 seconds make
it vertical boom that's a YouTube short
hey I just want to give you the you know
this week's market update in 60 seconds
or less thing one you need to know thing
two you need to know um you could do
answering specific questions hey people
always ask me what are the three things
I should look for if I'm trying to
decide what my budget is for my house
like we teach answer specific questions
one question one video if it's going to
take you longer than a minute then you
flip the make sure you have a dash Mount
or get one um we can look some of those
up too although probably you want a
specific one for your car
that works with your vent or whatever
but that's that's the move and and
forget the mic even I recommend it but
the car is quiet enough you already have
a phone get in your car 60 seconds or
less vertical horizontal if you want to
do like a five minute uh video maybe get
a little ruled notepad and write down a
few notes if you wanted to say give the
market update and you could say Hey you
know Sean here with your uh market
update for this week uh new home sales
this is what's happening these are some
of the opportunities this what rates are
at um if you need anything and and just
get started start before you're ready
because people overthink do I need a
fancy studio and of course if you're
going to do a listing and you want to do
a listing on your channel like you said
in Hawaii with a fancy videographer
maybe or or higher end gear because you
really want to show the house off and
you get somebody to do drone as well
that's that's kind of a separate
conversation so there is the ability to
expand the type of content formats you
have but what I want to do is start
simple I've learned that complexity is
the enemy of execution don't worry about
anybody else start with your phone start
Simple Start in your car or just at a
home office or your real estate office
and start answering specific questions
start doing some Market updates start
doing some vertical videos which can
also then be used on Instagram reels
Facebook reals which can bring you uh
leads in all places one of Anton's
strategies he is actually it's taking
about a year now he's doing a video
podcast he's doing some other things his
initial goal was to do one vertical
video a day more or less answering a
specific question per day a tip and in
some cases because he's looking at
investors too he'd say in the Pacific
Northwest do you see this Moss so
sometimes he's in the field maybe he has
somebody with him that just films him on
his phone no fancy gear see this Moss
one of the things we do to treat this
you know moss and protect homes like
this and get their roof just sharing
tips sharing value um and so 99% of
people are overthinking and I don't
blame them I mean it's there's a lot
that's running on your head you get into
your own selft talk and you got to just
make the decision to legitimately punch
fear in the face and press the record
button and then upload it and so what
Anton would do is he'd upload it on
Instagram Facebook reals Tik Tok YouTube
shorts now he's going super heavy
YouTube as you can and that's one of the
biggest things we teach it's kind of a
workflow we have some check list and
stuff so that you could kind of simplify
all this stuff but that would be my
thing I would say start with your phone
start simple and then you can always
scale up as you go and that's where
things kind of get exciting because
eventually money's coming in more
money's coming in you may have the
vision to build a media Studio similar
you know what if what if we got some
better microphones and some better
cameras and maybe eventually hiring a
team or video editors or an assistant
the big Vision eventually would be to
have a media company within your company
the media arm of whatever you're doing
in real estate whether that's just one
shreditor producer shooter editor kind
of person that you work with um one of
the things Anton did was he delegated to
the admin assistant at uh Keller
Williams to help caption the videos and
edit the videos on he had two Samsungs
he bought a new one that became his
phone and he used his old one dedicated
just to video you don't have to do that
but that's what he did and then he
delegated um hey it's very easy to throw
captions on these videos you can do it
yourself but think about it maybe
there's somebody in your office maybe
there's a a spouse or a partner that you
work with and he pays a little bit of
money to his son to also help edit which
is such a there's so many side benefits
I mean how cool is that to now be
getting enrolling people in your world
to start teaching them skills getting
them involved and Anton's a friend so
he's going to be okay if I say this like
when it first started out the captions
in my opinion look kind of ugly
sometimes and they were done a little
bit wrong and it's not how I would have
done it and he wasn't like opening the
videos you know like like we Pros would
do it think media but here was his
secret he started he started before he's
ready and now six months into it a year
into it a year and a half into it
investing in himself investing in
coaching investing in courses investing
in masterminds he's a whole another
person and he's still early on he's
becoming a a real estate media Mogul on
top of the other things and maybe that's
the last thing I'd say to an answer to
that it's like start before you're ready
skill up and invest in yourself and then
also be patient though because these
things do take time people are too hard
on themselves they try they upload four
YouTube shorts they um you know try this
for one week or one month the real key
is to stick with it over time especially
because your competitors they'll be too
busy they'll they won't figure out the
system to get all this done they will
get tired they will maybe get
discouraged if you can crash through all
those quitting points and
perser it's less about how great you're
going to be at this and the results
you're getting in six months it's more
interesting in 16 months how much deal
flow how much momentum you can build and
so to just sneak one other tip in there
is I would say like develop your mindset
and prepare your mind to not give up
when you don't get quick results in one
day too many or people if you try it for
one day or one week and then you're like
oh I listened to the podcast with
Melissa and Sean and it doesn't work I'd
be like um you didn't actually hear what
we were saying uh I've seen a lot of
people when they follow kind of our
Frameworks get quick results but for
most you you definitely want to have a
three-month six-month mindset and and
and also like what else you going to do
if the phone's not you know ringing and
if transactions are slow and you're
thinking about where to inv your time
and your week hustle on all kinds of
different Market marketing types of
things and and fulfillment types of
things but I think um the final tip
there to give a little more context is
also set a manageable schedule at first
made oh I'm setting the phone up in the
car and I did it wrong and oh it's kind
of frustrating it took a little bit
longer but I think you could sustain
even daily vertical videos which was by
the way Anton's plan one vertical video
a day he did it for like six months in a
row that's a what 31 videos a a month
you know times six um then he maybe fell
off a bit but it was down to like 20 and
still super significant and so commit to
to doing that and uh you'll be blown
away by the results over time you'll get
better over time so those are a few tips
well that's why there's even more
urgency in starting now because you
might not really see those results like
blowing up like you really want for a
year a year and a half down the road so
start now like you need to be starting
now so that you are getting those
results later on because like you're
saying it isn't immediate and so it is
going to take time to build that
influence so I know we're going to cover
this more on the the class that we're
doing but can you give maybe like the
top three videos that you'd recommend um
real estate agents create yeah I think
number one asq answer specific questions
so brainstorm with us especially if you
have a chance to pull your car over or
uh put the dumb barbells down uh
dumbbells down and open up your phone
open up a notepad and what are the top 5
10 15 20 questions that you just get
asked on on the phone from your
prospects from your clients they say Hey
you know if they're asking you for
advice what are what are the top of Mind
questions if you write down 20 of those
then you could plan out your next 20
days for your car situation Sun's Up you
got your coffee with you hey Sean
kelbach you know one of the questions
people ask or is now a good time to buy
should I buy now here's three things to
think about um how much house can you
afford here's three tips you know so
answering specific questions it would be
the first thing I would go to make a
list of those one video one question and
sometimes how long should the video be
again you could give the less than 60c
answer that works very good for vertical
video YouTube shorts and other places
but what's also interesting about these
this subject is is is now a good time to
buy could also be an hour video so you
you start learning that topics have kind
of some elasticity to them you could
answer the question in 30 seconds 3
minutes 30 minutes and all are good
because depending on the amount of
detail people want even the way the
YouTube algorithms a 30 minute mini
presentation let's say so in this case
maybe you eventually get your computer
set up webcam lighting a decent
microphone um I teach a lot I think
media Community would know that I do
this a lot it's a way on coffee with
canel I'll share my screen or in our web
classes I I teach off of like a
presentation a
presentation of good data some different
things and by the way if that feels too
overwhelming then stick with the shorter
but there's ways to scale it up so
that's kind of that's one would be
answering specific questions um these
are questions as well but as far as some
more specific video ideas consider what
people are searching for when they're
moving because one of the biggest
powerful things about YouTube is we're
living in a new world where people can
now do their own research about a
million things on their mind when
they're thinking about moving to a new
place and that's probably one of your
biggest opportunities for clientele and
so what was interesting is Anton and I
were having a conversation about snow
homish
County and this will maybe put some meat
on the bones strategically is you want
to think about the words people use the
search terms they use the cities they
might use and what was funny about sish
is I was like actually maybe not a lot
of people searching for that we started
joking it was like people think it it it
actually they don't know how to
pronounce it is it snow weish is it snow
homish you know and and what and so we
started saying are they searching North
Seattle are they searching Seattle are
they searching Seattle is the anchor are
they searching Pacific Northwest are
they searching Washington what are some
of the different different angles and
then are they searching best cities to
live in
Washington um
Seattle like rural so you and then the
answer to that too would be eventually
do all the above because each of those
becomes a different inroad because you
don't necessarily know but the more you
also talk to your customers prospects
and the the current customers and
Prospects you have and you think through
this YouTube lens and this search lens
and this media lens that gives you the
opportunity to then say okay so pros and
cons of of moving to a particular area
and you I know you said three ideas
these are really actually more than
three ideas and we get into some
specific tactics if I would put a third
on there we talk about one of our
favorite strategies is the versus
strategy and we use it like Canon R50
versus the Sony zv1 two different
cameras uh we our students use it like
uh element electrolytes versus relight
electrolytes um for those that are salty
and like to drink salt and get their day
started so uh you could think about
verses in so many different categories
it might even be trying to understand
Global conflicts or whatnot because
people are when they're in this point of
contrast so you might be talking about
like socialism versus capitalism it's a
good video idea explain both help me
understand it well how could that apply
to real estate so then back in sish the
area that I'd be thinking about shopping
in you might say like every
versus
Maryville pros and cons of these cities
cost and and what ends up happening too
is you get these all these specific
video ideas that are almost endless
because when somebody has narrowed down
a buying decision whether do they want
to buy their house this is what we've
learned they've narrowed down what
camera do I want to buy okay I know I'm
trying to decide between the Canon R50
and the Canon ZB E10 man it shows so
much intent by the time they're at that
level of education so then you could go
broader on some topics you could go
Regional you could like Nation best
cities in a in America cheapest cities
to you know you might tie into Boeing
which is up in the northwest or Amazon
and you know consequences like Amazon
might move so you can start getting into
news now we're going way past three so
one if you're listening to this register
for the class so we can put some more
handles on this but I hope that this is
stimulating a lot of ideas because the
opportunities are truly endless and the
way we observe YouTube right now it is a
blue ocean it is a wide openen
opportunity if you understand the
strategy if you punch fear in the face
and develop the skills if you commit to
this and you know scale it up over time
um I'm not trying to say it's easy but
there's nobody doing it there's nobody
do and and even people that are doing it
they're not doing it well they're being
very inconsistent with it and they're
definitely not doing it at the Strategic
level that we talk about here at think
media so um I'm not saying it's going to
pop off overnight but if you start
applying this even decently well you're
going to build so much more momentum and
eventually you're going to have 5 10 15
20 videos this might sound overwhelming
eventually you have 500 videos that are
all like different Pathways into your
business into your real estate business
one of the analogies we use is we say a
YouTube video is like an employee that
you pay once that works for you for free
for weeks months and years to come
meaning this how valuable would it be
for you to maybe you've hired somebody
on your team or you work for you know uh
some Reality Group and there's that
newer team member that that's the one
that does door hangers or that's the one
that you know is actually doing certain
showings what they're they're spending
their time doing something which gives
you more scale okay great so think about
a YouTube video it took you the time
maybe the energy maybe a little bit of
em emotional pressure because you're
getting started and and learning curve
Etc and time is money but once you
invest those resources into that video
and that video sits on the internet and
now over the next one month 6 months 12
months even years when just one person
is like do I move to Everett or
Marysville they find your video no like
and trust is built you put in the the
payment of time and energy into making
that video only one time but it's
bringing you a lead it's bringing you a
prospect a year later two years later
and you forgot about it so now why is
your phone running ringing off the hook
why are are is the form on your website
being filled out at a crazy level and
you're like man there's leads coming in
every day there's leads coming in every
month 50 100 150 200 leads qualified
because this person has narrowed down
that they want to either move to this
city or that city they're calling you
because now they just want to decide
they have narrowed down that they kind
of like your Vibe because again we would
teach not just being practical but
weaving in Little Things uh about your
personality which you would probably
already do your your social skills a
great book How to Win Friends and
Influence People I mean these are some
of the things that um are the skill sets
that work great in service uh positions
and so as you start learning how to
weave that into your
videos you you did all this work that
we're talking about I know it sounds
like work Thomas Edison said opportunity
is missed by most people because it's
dressed in overalls and it looks like
work yeah a learning curve here yeah
there's some work but what's waiting for
you on the other side wealth impact and
serving your customers and helping
people and so if you're listening to
this you can do this and um those are a
few thoughts uh one of the most common
follow-up questions we get when you
start talking about the asq method is
how do I find these questions that
people are asking and I would say like
talk to someone like me because as
Sean's talking through all this like all
I can think Sean is I would would
specifically you mentioned the question
of um is now the right time to buy I
would watch a video that said is now the
right time to buy in Las Vegas because
that's going to trigger something in me
that's like Well there must be something
specific to my city and I want to know
and you're talking about um in like it
could be is now the right time to buy in
Washington and you just can talk about
anything that's specific to the state
you know the migration of people and how
that's affecting prices and stuff like
there's all those nuances that people
can speak to so talk to somebody who is
looking or is a newbie in your in your
area so in real estate and ask them what
their questions are and make videos on
that right is that 100% And what you
also discover is that it really is
endless I mean even as we talk I'm like
there's certain states that have also
certain incentives like buy certain
programs you know again you start
educating people like so there's also
the opportunity of course as a loone
officer to do this and then there's also
an opportunity as an agent to get
educated about that side of things to
bring maybe the loan officer you work
with on as a guest now they're sitting
with you in the car you're like hey
today I'm here and let's talk about
rates let's talk about locking in rates
let's talk about credit let's talk about
you know uh how to improve your credit
and all these different things so it
really does uh get exciting that's why
we like to say you cannot steer a parked
car get moving get making the videos get
a few under your belt but eventually
this this is a fact there is
unlimited videos and good topics to make
that will bring you business and the
reason I can say that for a fact is not
only how expansive the different details
are about just kind of the complexities
and different you know schools
restaurants what it's like to live
certain areas safety crime like all
kinds of different things but it's also
then always changing it's always a new
year it's always a new quarter it's
always a new situation with rates so you
actually have the that's why the media
company idea is it's not like you're
you're you're thinking about I'm going
to start creating content for a while
and then stop you could do that and
receive some benefit I think one of the
big mindset shifts is really this needs
to become a habit and a lifestyle this
is just modern marketing and if you're
not in a healthy relationship with Sam
you're going to lose in 2024 what's that
mean Sam stands for sales and marketing
you always have to be nurturing Sam
encouraging Sam what is Sam's Love
Languages the five love languages Gary
Chapman you got to love Sam and a lot of
people also sometimes don't love Sam can
I just I mean I don't I don't know if I
want to do sales and marketing no you
that so I mean you're in business you're
a service provider so so you not only
want to be Skilling up in your sales and
marketing um Sam is a is a big deal and
and and by the way YouTube's future is
incredibly bright I mean there there's
more people watching content than ever
before but and we see for sure a
fiveyear u Horizon but I could see a
Whole Decade of and Beyond of YouTube um
prospering but you can't lose doing this
because the skill sets you got to learn
regardless is even if it wasn't YouTube
10 years from now you still got to learn
video because it could be video
somewhere you still got to learn how to
communicate on video how to hook how to
grab attention um how to create the
teams and systems around this so that's
kind that's why would also say a media
company YouTube's the clear winner clear
leader owned by Google experts would say
internally externally that it's really
not going anywhere so it's a great it's
great ground to build on but futurewise
you want to Future proof your business
by elevating your marketing period
That's the bigger category that we're
talking about here how can you be
worldclass at Marketing in such a way
that you are never starving or hungry
for leads that you're never dig your
well before you're thirsty that you've
created so much momentum and so much
business and such a full Pipeline and
such an endlessly full Pipeline and
let's think about the day-to-day
practical like just putting in the work
and getting one or two leads but let's
also talk about what happens eventually
that as you skill up and as you master
what we teach and as you commit to this
and as you commit to it over the Long
Haul 99% of content creators we coach
eventually I don't know if it's going to
be in 3 months I don't know if it's
going to be in s months they'll get a
breakout video and we call it vfm viral
for me
so it may not be a billion views in fact
in in real estate especially in a niche
City there's it's we're not talking
about you know Charlie bit my finger or
like some Taylor Swift music video it's
a different kind of category but when we
say viral for me there's so much value
you can have in real estate getting even
10 100 views a video because if it's the
right views that could lead to a
transaction great if you get 5,000
10,000
75,000 155 ,000 views and you start
thinking about having the right things
in place so that those views can
translate into people giving you their
phone number their email you can text
them whatever filling out your form you
you were sitting there and you're like
man it's kind of been a SLO but it's
been great because i' I've got you know
100 leads a month about six to s% of
those convert so I got you know six to
seven transactions a month that'd be
pretty good you know uh not even that
you know one to two transactions a month
like let's be real practical but then it
all hits because you to this 45 days
from now 90 days from now you go oh my
gosh you go to sleep you wake up you're
like Sean and Mel were right and a video
you're like it just keeps getting views
it's like being it's being sucked into
the algorithm and then and then your
team's also a little overwhelmed or
you're overwhelmed because you're like
you wake up you got 155 people to follow
up with like in one day and then it
keeps coming in day after day when you
commit to the YouTube game that's
waiting for you if you commit to
Skilling up you know learning this like
it it just happens and and is with all
the expertise we have and we teach a 7h
hour framework ultimately in our course
video raet Academy we just say just keep
working the system just keep following
the seven RS and of course like every
time we want we wish the video would do
amazing but what I've just learned being
on YouTube for 17 years now since I was
first doing it for my local church um is
that it's just eventually going to
happen when you follow the system and
sometimes I'm like this will be the
video and I'm like oh it wasn't the
video it still did good got 2,500 views
great I'm willing to do that all day
long if if that was all I ever got I
would do that if I've mapped it towards
the economics that make my business work
but then I'm always surprised we just
look back over the last year the last
couple months and I was like I never
thought that episode would have been the
one that got 75,000 views well I'm
shocked that that YouTube short and on
on a in our Niche uh one of our YouTube
shorts on think media right now is
literally at 37 million views
hilariously too I would have never
guessed that it would have gone to that
37 million Melissa views and and that's
literally what's waiting for people
listening to this but it's waiting again
on the other side of positioning
yourself right and uh and just getting
into it committing to it over the Long
Haul and what are you willing to number
one of course make this practical I know
money's got to come in in a in a
reasonable amount of time or deal flow
or leads has to come in but are you
willing to do this for 3 years if your
breakout moment was three and a half
years from now are you willing to do
this you know for five five years and I
hope you say yes meaning are you willing
to commit to marketing because so yes
and so if if you can do well for the
next 12 to 24 to 36 months great but but
are you willing to commit to this now
and get a little bit uncomfortable so
that in three and a half years all a
sudden you're like dude my my business 5
to 10x and what happens when rates
really drop and what happens when no
matter how long the real estate
recession or the freeze is what happens
while others have gotten taken out but
you're still here and you survived but
now you're powerfully positioned so that
when the wind comes back and fills your
sales maybe it's not even just your
sales you built a fleet boom all of a
sudden you're like oh then it got super
crazy and then people go man you were so
lucky wow all of a sudden you just like
your business like 10x you got so lucky
and you're like no I didn't get lucky I
actually started positioning myself at
the beginning of 2024 to capitalize on
all of the above I was very intentional
and strategic and I just put the right
ingredients in place I don't like to
judge My Life by The Harvest I'm reaping
I like to judge My Life by the seeds
that I'm
sewing and when I think about seeds just
smart strategic YouTube videos planted
over time confident that I'm going to
reap a harvest I don't necessarily know
when I think about the Bible vers it
says do not grow weary in doing good cuz
in due time you will reap a harvest if
you don't give up that's what you're
doing you're stacking your marketing and
your assets and your resources every
YouTube video is like a seed that you're
planting just keep watering this system
and then allow it to grow and you're
going to be shocked by the Harvest
waiting for you on the other side one of
the other most common follow-up
questions we get when we talk through
this is competition like how there's so
much competition out there so how do
people stand out um in their individual
videos well I think what's kind of cool
is actually number one um nobody's you
and so I think you should
amplify you you got to be U times two
you know you were born an original don't
die a copy and here's what I mean is for
some people they have a preference for
who they work with be that gender be
that ethnicity be be that age so these
are things that you just kind of want to
amplify and if you are comfortable and
and you're in your thumbnail meaning the
YouTube thumbnail that you upload a
photo of you might be the very thing
that repels somebody which is also great
because it's a filtering system if they
had some if they had some reason they
didn't want to work with you cuz like I
just want to work with a a female agent
not a male agent great the internet was
filtering that for you you know like but
thinking about how you present yourself
you uh you know one of the things we
teach is people don't just follow the
what they follow the why people like to
connect with and work with people that
have shared beliefs and shared values
that's also why peppering in things into
your video that is true it's also has a
practical marketing purpose because when
someone starts saying okay this person
was giving me good information but then
I also started to learn about them like
oh like they're a real family person and
which is there's single agents are can
brush and maybe the single agent
perspective is like the dating scene
here is great flip side is the family's
perspective is like the communities and
the schools and the churches scene here
is great these are all unique things
about you so I think it's about just
truly being you because you're going to
serve the people that are naturally
attracted to you the best but you know
present yourself the best way and weave
in those little details that's what
makes the competition irrelevant because
literally nobody is you now also then
saying that I think one way to send out
from the competition is just doing it
because the competition isn't and I mean
that sincerely that like if they are
doing it they're probably not doing it
consistently and if they um or or at all
and they're also probably not doing it
strategically so even though you see
people you start using think media's bag
of tricks and you've got 36 distinct
advantages over the person who's not
making this that video but let's take it
all the way down to okay they actually
they do kind of look like you you know
sort of the same Vibe same age same
situation crowded City bigger city okay
fine um what I also start to think about
is just doing it and getting in the game
you don't even have to be number
one you can still do very well if you're
number 10 or 25 by again just some
people are afraid that like the question
was already asked um or answered by
another competitor in my city yeah but
you should do it too and well that
competitor's already getting 25,000
views a video they're established well
why don't you start and get the 250
views it makes me think like well Coke
already made Cola so nobody else can
well no Pepsi could well that's the big
two they took the whole Market no
there's like Jones Soda RC Cola if
anybody knows that throwback and it
makes me think of drones when I think
about tech because we go to CES and what
I learned was that
DJI the main consumer drone company has
like 80% of the market of drones which
is wild and could be discouraging but
then I we flip it we walk through the
halls of CES which is the Consumer
Electronic Show in Las Vegas and I'm
like there's like 40 drone companies
here and and they're making millions of
dollars a year now maybe DJI is making
billions of dollars a year but I think
that's the the mindset block when it
comes to competition I'm not necessarily
saying you're going to be the top dog
number one but back to the fact fact
that 80% of agents are not even going to
be in business in the next 12 months
when you get into the YouTube game just
get your piece of the pie which might be
enough to survive or might be enough to
double the business you're doing right
now Etc so yeah the competition is doing
it you just do it also like you do it as
well get into the game take a you might
have a smaller piece of market share but
that market share is still there and in
a 2024 World you're not too late not
only have most agents still not started
and most people in the real estate game
across the board they still have not
started they're not doing it they're
especially not doing it in local regions
um so you're you're not too late and
then also most are not doing it well and
they're not doing it consistently so
what is cool about that is there's also
going be different factors of talent and
Charisma but I think Talent is overrated
hustle beats Talent when talent doesn't
hustle and most won't hustle they won't
put in the work they won't get
uncomfortable so there's certain things
you you can't control like maybe
genetics but the things you can control
is like work ethic how much you going to
study how much you going to invest in
yourself how much you going to put in a
little bit extra are you willing and I
don't think this would surprise people
but I think people underestimate just
how many people kind of do the bare
minimum or just or they just don't know
this information and so I just say just
just do it just because there's
competition um I mean one final
illustration there is like when there is
something that is desirable and people
got to move even if it's less
transactions there's still transactions
they still want to move they still want
to buy houses move up move down sell
downsize kids are out of the house empty
nesters it's always happening right it's
just never going to not happen I think
about think media so you could say we're
one of the bigger players talking about
cameras and over the years one of the
famous cameras that we talked about was
the Canon M50 and we've probably made 30
videos about the Canon M50 that have all
gotten anywhere from maybe 30,000 views
to close to a million views
and you would think okay well think
media has actually probably exhausted
this topic I would agree that's that's
pretty true and well they're already
established millions of subscribers so
what's the point of trying okay that's
the mistake because if you go and search
the Canon M50 and you type that into
YouTube and then you scroll and you look
at how many different channels have
talked about it the same things that
we've talked about it and different Ang
different angles on it
meaning maybe it the best you know
Wildlife photography lenses for the
Canon M50 we've actually never done that
once that's a different angle see if
you've never done that county that City
that Niche thing in real estate it's a
different angle but even direct same
videos as ours essentially topic it is
shocking there is thousands of people
that have made videos about the Canon
M50 and while maybe some of our videos
have gotten a million views there are
thousands of people that have gotten
5,500 views 18,000 views 32,000 views
300,000 views and we kind of sto talking
about it because even though it's still
a great older camera um it's a little
bit more outdated now there's people
saying is the Canon M50 still relevant
in 2024 and that video gets 33,000 views
so competition like competition is is is
an excuse for most that it just isn't
true just get in the game like get your
hat in the ring it doesn't mean you'll
be number one but are you okay being a
smaller drone company are you okay being
Jon soda or RC Cola and still crushing
it in a smaller Niche I would recommend
and we'll link it up in the show notes
that people listen to our positioning
episodes of the podcast because we
talked about that the book positioning
and I break down all these takeaways as
related to kind of online marketing was
that exact thing your goal is not to try
to defeat Coke or Pepsi your goal is to
figure out your unique difference will
be the other way you approach
competition Andor your goal is also to
just take that small market share if if
someone's doing Millions a year are you
okay doing a couple hundred k a year
because of the smaller smaller market
share I would think most agents
listening would be like yeah that sounds
really nice I would love to do that
that's the kind of thing waiting for you
and of course you know if you're in some
super small town and that like the
economics of couple 100 Grand a year
might not exist cuz you're like Sean
there's 1,00 people in my town you're
like okay well that's then that's a
whole other thing that's a conversation
about moving or going there's like
YouTube or not there's literally not
enough volume no matter what the market
is because there's 16 people on a dirt
road okay you know so there's there's
all kinds of factors but um I I would
say stop worrying about the competition
get started and you'll be shocked by the
results when you stick with it you've
shared so many ideas and strategies that
I'm sure um are just getting everyone's
Wheels spinning so what are the exact
like succinct next three steps for any
real estate agent listening to this yeah
so the next three steps I mean I
actually want to challenge step number
one is go record your first video right
now like as soon like like oh I got a
busy day no you don't come on relax like
you I we all do like so you know
schedule either immediately after this
podcast not even schedule do it
immediately after this podcast or do it
by end of day man when you feel that
fire you can make it happen happen I
know it's like uh for example if my wife
Sonia needs something no matter how busy
my day is and I and she says I need that
by five it wasn't on my list before she
said she needed it but guess what's
going to happen Melissa it's going to be
done by five like that's things have
been changed because priorities have
shifted and we we stop making excuses
it's like give yourself a deadline and I
would say make your first video and
saying that make it vertical less than
60 seconds shoot it on your phone upload
it on YouTube YouTube shorts now I'm
assuming you have started a channel and
if you haven't then do that like Gmail
oh Sean Melissa I don't know how to
start a YouTube channel okay I I almost
want to like not let you listen to the
podcast anymore if you just said that in
your mind oh how do I actually set up a
channel I'm
upset be go to Google start YouTube
channel click top link follow steps and
and so I would imagine though if you're
here you've probably already at least Le
you have your channel maybe it doesn't
have a little Avatar image yet or a
cover image yet but you have a Gmail
address and um maybe you haven't
activated your channel just do the steps
sit down at a computer do it on your
phone get your channel started upload
that YouTube short what if I sound dumb
what do I an no just do it just get it
done you could always private it later
you could always make it unlisted later
but that is going to get you a little
bit of momentum so do your first video
and then after that get it uploaded step
two is write down 5 to 10 questions that
come to mind after listening to this
episode if you were you know pulled out
that legal pad you may might already
have those but now rather than trying to
when you're kind of tired and you wake
up and the coffee hasn't hit yet you're
like I don't even know what to talk
about today that's why if you have a
list of 5 to 10 then shoot those over
the next few days daily if you want but
just keep the momentum going and just
give it a shot every day hold yourself
to to try to answer you know like you're
talking to a friend friend someone calls
you hey quick question for you um maybe
it's actually somebody you would coach
on your team or something like hey um or
just a friend a prospect hey I got to
run to a meeting but I'm just curious
like I'm trying to talk to my wife and
she's not sure if if now is a good time
to buy what would you say and I I have
one Mee minute before the meeting oh I
don't have a lot of time but uh here's
what I would say like creativity works
best in constraints There's a constraint
so and and so keep it vertical but the
number three would be register for the
class I think do not miss um this
upcoming class this actually will be the
first one I think we've ever done on the
real estate topic I've probably spoken
at probably over 10 real estate events
now on YouTube uh in different formats
but we've never done like a free online
class breaking down step by step our
strategies um and uh that's kind of a
no-brainer so then you've got some
momentum and by the way when you take
action on step one and two you'll be
ready for the class you don't have to do
anything to show up to the class if you
just want to get more information
certainly but if you want to most
powerfully position yourself you'll
already unlock some more insights just
by what you've learned between now and
then and bring your questions because I
think we'll take as much time as we can
for the Q&A um and so you and I will be
there to answer your questions so
register for the class Link in the
description I forget what the URL is
what is it again realtube class.com
realu class.com that's coming up soon
probably when this podcast drop so
register for that class I hope this has
been valuable and those are the three
things that I would do thanks for
joining us for this episode and if this
is just a surface level conversation on
strategies for real estate agents with
YouTube so definitely make sure that you
are going to join us on that class at
real tube class.com that's where we're
going to be able to go a lot deeper and
give you really those steps to get to
start building on YouTube so we'll see
you there